[Music]
and in anti paradise news submitted by
Saturday cartoons Americans are
mysteriously dying in the Dominican
Republic yo I've been [ __ ] reading
about like drink soda or something did
drink alcohol drinking from the minibar
and are like just from the morning but
yeah alcohol and then Dan of dying it's
not just that though a lot of [ __ ] is
just surfacing which makes me think
conspiracy but I'll get to that oh hell
yeah that's a good team catch me up
alright so there have been about six
people that have died
damn in the last year during there's
this Americans American American even
one of the cast members of Shark Tank
Barbara her family member brother
her brother okay he recently died in the
Dominican Republic - said it was like a
heart attack or something they're all
this is all happening in like the same
kind of like resort regions and it's the
same kind of event the leaves with death
right like minibar our attacks a night
attack they keep reporting it as a heart
problems or like water in their lungs
Wow and yes yeah so like the first
person that died her name was Yvette she
was 40 oh sorry 51 years old she died
June 2018 of a heart attack is what
they're saying but then now that all
these other people have been dying
they're saying that there's just way too
many similarities and that doesn't all
these family members are saying that
this is [ __ ] is suspicious like we need
a [ __ ] these people travel by
themselves no some of them it's like
couples have died like that they're
celebrating their anniversary or a bald
avantime yeah they both died yeah so
like the next one July 2018 David
Harrison 45 died at the Hard Rock Hotel
& Casino in Ghana and he died of a heart
attack and his death certificate also
listed pulmonary edema which is
accumulation of fluid in the lungs and
that that caused respiratory failure
which was the
is happening is being done by the
Dominican Republic or please send the
body back here and then they like
they're like yep we conclude this is
what it is yeah I'm not sure but I think
it's there yeah what are they more
concerned about the fact that they're
dying from heart attacks of the fact
that there is water in their lungs too
well the fact that they're all similar
that even before they died like what
they did which was like drink alcohol
from he's a minibar from the bar and
then and then they they start saying
that they are feeling sick and then next
thing you know they just they don't wake
up the next morning that's that when I
see a kid put his mouth over the whole
water fountain I never drink from that
water fountain 10,000 kids did that
before him - yeah and I lament risk we
always have this you see the guy that's
trying to deep the hall yeah it's a let
it run for at least 10 seconds you count
along I don't even go back to ever again
we all [ __ ] who our water fountain used
to be brown the water that would come
out and then you have to hold it for a
minute
actually yeah rusty Brown dude but you
know where apparently the dirtiest
candies you know I don't know they don't
really have them anymore but you know
those those when you go to a grocery
store you buy like the candy by the
pound yeah they say like that's the most
distant their hands and jizz what about
that God was a sweet factory or
something at the mall yeah but they're
more like Senate yeah they're like more
they don't leave that you million
grocery stores you know they have that
sprouts yeah open huge like barrels and
[ __ ] hands are going talking about
grocery store salad bars man I always
looks nuts Oh like that Whole Foods oh
yeah the guy he likes you in the grocery
store something for the soup he's got
the ladle he drank out of it guys I've
been like chillin on fast food as a
whole I don't really trust people even
your nose too sometimes I don't design
them good so you pee on it and it
splashes back but I know when it
splashes back it splashes back with the
other person's pee at my feet
dude just what do you walk in like the
movie theater you go to the bathroom at
the movie theater any movie theater and
you can just the air the [ __ ]
particulate in the air you can feel a
thickness you know you know how I stood
me up I've been seeing this recently I
don't know if there's like an upscale
thing when you go to the bathroom in
some places they have ice in the urinals
maybe I'm saying that I had seen that
yeah that's a low scale thing oh it's
mostly I think it's the cooks they need
it because the ice machine keeps making
it and it starts to overflow so they
just take and you just throw in the
urinal I know it's gonna melt right yeah
I always be like why am i peeing on ice
but I'll do it I'd be like I it becomes
fun like you melt you melt it with your
pee yeah then you feel powerful you feel
power let me just put it there just cuz
it's gonna it's easier to drain out that
way
well why can't they flush it flat lay it
down the toilet does it's solid true
that's true you never seen a urinal huh
that's cute I know they look like okay
okay why you when they're looking at the
urinal you're not gonna win this you
don't belong in there you know it's you
know what's crazy about all this - its I
started getting into some more news
about the Dominican Republic where it's
not just deaths but like people getting
raped
rape yeah there was just one story where
this lady she was like you know chillin
with her family and and she she was like
hungry she wanted a midnight oh yes I
saw that that she went out to go get
some food and then she got dragged into
like a spoiler drew and beat up the
workers and in shred of that happening
in a cruise no no this was at a resort
and then she went to the front desk and
then they didn't want to investigate it
or nothing it was a guy unique wearing a
uniform yeah and then other women
started coming out about this stuff
that's scary
yeah she was lepers daddy I've heard
like horror stories about like if you go
like to not just did Dominican Republic
or even someplace in Mexico like you
won't get mugged for like your wallet
like you'll wake up in a bathtub for
lice and your kidneys gone yeah yeah
please take my money instead of my
wallet in my debit card yeah kind of
need the rim
I'm Rich's pot of money and you gotta
work so hard to do the surgery like damn
I'll just pay you instead yeah that's
crazy man what do you think's really
going on just oh so I think this is I
don't want to make people scared but
like people dying and resorts and all
these crazy things happening is pretty
normal right but then mostly normalizing
suitable time it's just not something
it's kind of like an unwritten law that
like people just don't publicize this
stuff because it's bad for business
people fall off and cruises all the time
and they don't go get you and I'm sure
more people die in Vegas then they do in
the Dominican Republic because a lot of
people die in Vegas oh yeah four
suicides and all kinds of other things
right like what yeah cuz one of the he's
a fan if he's watching but he's told me
you the security guard there and he told
me like you know it's it's like a third
of the people come to conventions in
Vegas a third come to party and a third
come to die yeah what's there like a lot
of people died it would've been lumpy
would it be shocking if every single
hotel room had someone died there oh
really but think about all the think
about oh no think about all the tourist
places right millions of people go there
there's gonna be accidents just
statistically
yeah right there's gonna be that's what
I'm saying but that's what I'm saying
though okay so so that that you gotta
get in your head that this is normal
like it happens to tourist areas it just
happens even even we go to a while ah
right
a lot of tourists die there like because
they don't understand the waves they get
into act they do crazy [ __ ] and that
[ __ ] never goes onto news or anything
because they rely on tourism so places
like the Dominican Republic they rely on
this [ __ ] who's bringing this [ __ ] out
to cause people to stop going there for
tourism what do you think do you think
it's like a bigger like a government
what do you think I don't think it's
government I think it's people that's
trying to buy the resorts so they want
the flow of traffic to stop so
then people be scared and then they
start losing money and in the resorts
get a little bankrupt and then they
could come in and buy it and then change
all the marketing and then what's
happening oh there's a lot of media
saying that tourists were dying and like
getting murdered like just on the street
like some crazy-ass [ __ ] and then I was
even scared of going but we ended up
relieved I wanted a couple of cruises to
Mexico I never got off the boat though
there's a lot of my work that when I
went but these guys are all dinah the
same weird thing yeah that could be just
a serial-killer thing but then all this
[ __ ] there's more than that I think
that's coming out that makes me think
why well what's more than that the rates
and what did you see the I think you
said something else
oh the rashes and stuff like people were
saying that they were getting rashes on
their body like this is one of them oh
yeah what's it like a tattoo
yeah no it's already oh my dude I get
rashes like this because of too much Sun
I get like that when I jerk off if you
lost you can with the underestimate that
to like overconsumption of alcohol can
lead to some [ __ ] - so maybe they just
was turning up a lot I mean the way they
were reporting it it's like everybody
from the Dominican Republic's could have
baseball that's a conspiracy - okay is a
good conspiracy it's cuz there's
genetics man yo what's Mahalo just got
shot in Dominican Republic yeah David
Ortiz he's a baseball player papi dude
dude I'm the articles did I have to go
through the find out if he's alive or
not every single article was just that
he got shot him and he medically evac
from that yeah yeah the Red Sox I sent
like a plane but apparently like the
details that are coming out about it
yeah it was a bait apparently was i dude
it was a dude it was two off-duty cops
that shot him they were hired by was it
a drug lord that he was sleeping with
his wife they got paid $8,000 to do the
hit well that's it
that's a little bit of money he knows no
this I mean not saying that I know the
prices on what it takes to get a guy
here but he's a pretty high-profile go
right yeah don't like him it depends on
where you're at though cuz in Bali eight
grand is a long one alright true yeah
four hundred thousand Dominican pesos I
rather be here where we only have school
shootings that's [ __ ] tight dude yeah
that's in safe America we got drug lords
too but they're trying to keep their
neighborhoods clean like mm-hmm
dude even a my [ __ ] where I eat that's
what that's what the drug lords are
saying here yeah and even in Mexico a
lot of the resorts are safe because
they're owned by a lot of girls yeah a
lot of the other cops are just different
out of my store they pull you over be
like give me $300 you be like I got it
you're going to jail yep mmm happy to
him no saw me and my buddy we were all
Marines and then we're going down to
Rosarito hangout and so just thinking
all were American or protected or like
but we got what we were just driving and
in this cop he's a cop pickup truck
pulled us over and they all had a case
and stuff and they get out and then
they're like hey case yeah cuz they're
just out of the back of the truck like
dude what about pointing at me one so
scary but it is yeah and then so they uh
they they started searching our stuff
and my hey we're like military we're
good we came down at a party and then
they're like I don't care your ability
yeah well you guys are you guys are what
did they say to you all you guys were
speeding and then really all we weren't
speeding because we know we're in a
different country you know like well if
unless you guys have a little bit extra
we're gonna have to take you into jail
so we just all emptied our wallet just
give them what the [ __ ] this is crazy
yeah that's act by the cops how much was
it you think I mean I probably only had
like 60 bucks everyone probably like 60
no party with 60 bucks you can treat my
cheap damasco all 19 years old you still
go party yeah did how gonna for a hotel
they just nothing about how did you
afford anything else maybe a credit card
a what if you guys got pulled over again
what if all right well you can't take
somebody to jail for speeding but I mean
you're in another country
they'll probably make some [ __ ] up like
I don't even know I'm like you have
these cop guys these crazy ass weapons
I'm like I don't even know what's going
on and this seems like a lot to pull up
with a bunch of aks in a pickup truck
no they just made my not even been cops
no they always are just sitting in the
back in the bag open yeah in the bed how
did you have one porn engine oh um I
remember I was going to TJ to fly out to
go visit whatever so like my family
member picked me up at the border cuz
cheaper to fly out if you're in Mexico
and then so we were heading to the
airport and just down a regular
residential street they were in their
pickup truck and as ours we were driving
by like my uncle he ended up flashing
his lights at the cops and I'm like what
are you doing what are you doing cuz I
could see that they were pointing it
right at us and then I passed by and I
just like who's aiming it right at me
nothing why well this is [ __ ] scary
just because I don't know it's TJ it's
[ __ ] dangerous that's right hey I
heard gunshots every night in TJ yeah
it's [ __ ] dangerous you'll just go to
like any building you'll see bullet
holes yeah Dana just never got out the
book I was like I'm jealous I was good
[Music]